once you establish and define this okay
these two you just follow what we call
me crawler ease results that are proven
on the basis of some other kind of thing
that just happens okay so we did other
bases we got to this right the
derivative of a to the X for any real
number a is a B X log a fantastic but
now we're gonna make a bigger become a
overtook logs okay and this will sort of
a lot of mysteries we already developed
earlier in the course
these were I'm going to begin by
definition again I've got these two
things now what am I going to do with
them and how am I gonna get them to long
hmm you can see why cuz if the X is
actually a would statement in disguise
agreed any every exponential statement
is a long statement in disguise how
would I rewrite it if it were a log
equation okay so I'm gonna make X to the
subject and you could put it either way
but that's going to be equal to log base
a of Y so what am i doing okay so that's
just bad now on the basis of this like
nothing has changed this is still the
situation right so I'm gonna take this
derivative which I already know and I'm
going to turn it upside down I'm not of
the age of sort of thing to do this is a
fraction at the Y and the X it's wiser
to run
so now just think about water what we do
so it's 105 PS
how you feeling so far it makes sense is
I haven't done anything you know
incredibly yeah I am what I'm doing by
the way is I'm trying to get over into
logarithms are the inverse operation of
X penetrance they undo what
exponentially do they swap inputs and
outputs right so that's what I'm trying
to get some swapping convoluted okay now
the last little thing to see maybe X
right
I actually know what e to the X is it's
kind of weird to have this as a function
of X because now this on the left hand
side is differentiating with respect to
Y do you notice that this is
differentiate that with respect to Y so
what an enemy would expect this to also
be in terms of 1 so DX 1 dy is in fact
whatever what do you create that because
even the X the first thing I wrote is y
equals e DX yeah yeah yeah okay now do
you know although you're like we didn't
return it do is we talk about dummy
variables dummy variables it's like this
X Y you teach theta
they're all just labeled right better
actually mean anything I can swap them
out whoever I like look at this line
look at it really really what's I find
my own watch what happens now if I take
every single variant I mean there's only
two all wires and all the exes and swap
them around that's all inverses are
doing right there just swapping inputs
and outputs so what I get over here is y
equals log X of swapping variant in the
derivative I should swap those variables
to that should be dy DX and the last one
there on the right hand side
I was no complicated at all why did I
swap one less one because I really want
everything in terms of X's right like I
don't want X equal of why were you just
saying Y is the dependent variable that
X is the independent one this is the
usual way that you phrase things so just
to make a little obvious
we usually say Y is a function of X now
this is what's brilliant about it right
do you remember when we were integrating
and differentiate we said this right we
said this and there's an integral
statement that goes with it right if you
integrate this what do you get to
remember you did the opposite thing
instead of subtracting you add right
instead of multiplying you'd about to
divide and then of course you've got
your hearing you little coaxing
integration now I said that that's true
it's true all the time it's true for
positive numbers negative numbers it's
true for 0 it's different fractions even
except not 1 and here is why right when
you have x equals negative 1 over here
that is in fact whatever X right the
integral of x to the 5 negative 1 of
whatever X is not anymore polynomials
like these things it's something
different all together right she wanted
all obvious that's the case we had to
take this winding journey through
Exponential's and bases and then we got
to Long's and so this this here and this
here the two things are put in boxes are
pretty sure that's it but she things are
pretty blue boxes they kind of like your
keys for this entire all Exponential's
along which you combine them with chain
rule and you're buying them as products
or as questions but you're gonna be
using basically those two guns ok this
time here is kind of a bit of food
he's less common he does come up
sometimes okay the lion's share of stuff
is people